they were showing us storyboards that
i'm like you want me to
work on that
i pushed really hard to rebuild this in
cg wow you know no joke what you know
the filmmakers like when we started
showing them stuff they couldn't believe
it
so you worked on one of the most iconic
visual effects shots of modern cinema in
my opinion
thanks to audible for sponsoring this
episode stick around at the end to see
how you can get a free trial for a month
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
we're joined by a very special guest
today brian grill brian is a visual
effects supervisor artist composer he's
done it all brian tell us a little bit
about what it means to be a visual
effects supervisor on set you work
directly with the filmmakers and then
for me for example i work for a company
called scanline after filming i come
back and then i have a team of artists
that i work with you know we can get up
to 150 artists you're basically not only
you know trying to keep a technical a
creative vision but also you know you
have a crew of people you got to keep
motivated you know get to the end uh
make the filmmakers happy brian so what
are some of the earliest projects that
you worked on i'm an old guy been around
i started uh at digital domain apollo 13
fifth element in titanic we're the first
three movies i worked on you know i
started as a compositing artist and uh
very fortunate that digital domain at
the time was writing uh nuke and then
nuke just became this tool you know and
now the whole industry it's like it's
bread and butter i can't wait to see you
break down some of the iconic scenes
you've worked on as well as just kind of
helping us understand how the technology
in the the world of visual effects have
changed from the 90s all the way till
now
so you worked on one of the most iconic
visual effects shots
of modern cinema in my opinion there's a
couple you know you get the the bullet
time spin right
you got
i really adjustable time spin so
but it's also because it has one of the
most iconic visual effects breakdowns in
my opinion like at the time this came
out
my god my god
[Music]
what's cool about this it's this is
one of the last movies i worked on that
it was uh miniatures
and cg together like these managers were
shot at ilm uh and then we you know
added all our cg
look at that that's that's a model and
then we add that's uh cg splinters
[Music]
i just
i love how he takes his hand off the
railing and then it finally disappears
yeah
to your point like i just love that he
is just in such bewilderment
that he can't believe that this is
happening and he doesn't even flinch
like yeah you know his hand goes on the
railing and the railing right behind
right where he touched just
obliterates
yeah and that's what makes it i think
iconic is the that performance like the
fingers still out as if he's continuing
it yeah what i notice when i watch it is
that in every single shot the
destruction always starts in the very
back of the shot and works its way
towards camera even if you flip the
camera there it comes towards us you
flip it there it comes towards us and it
always follows that pattern which is
super smart because
then you get to see everything nothing
it's not like something blows up in the
foreground and you're like it just
covers everything like what what's
happening back there so
what's real and what's not
okay so the they built the the the set
it was basically like balsa wood we
broke this up into
into multiple passes so we we did a
clean version where he walks down
you know where nothing is blowing up
then we uh for safety reasons he
couldn't be
you know there what what what kind of
safety reasons
were what was the safety challenge you
know you ever got a splinter yeah
those splinters
hurt
okay especially if you don't get all of
it this would be like two or three
winners at the same time totally
they had charges and it was a motion
control camera so the the camera was
moving
super fast
yeah but shooting at super high rate oh
so so basically so motion control rigs
usually are to match two shots with a
similar angle but this was also
re-timing the speed of the rig to
account for the frame rate right that
it's being filmed at so it can match the
camera except one's in slow motion and
one's not right so it was multiple
passes for the different uh beats of
destruction and then we put all those
passes together and then we had to then
digitally
explode it
wow you know no joke what that like that
is incredible that's
cg that looks so photoreal when they
shot it it was timed and i pushed really
hard to rebuild this in cg so that we
could re-time it and create these events
and we weren't locked in
to what they shot on set like the way
that they animate the the railing
wiggling
after it breaks to like show the flex
and vibrations still within it yeah
that's like one of those touches where i
mean i feel like i would i would totally
miss that i'm like boom like sweet
particles cool shards and then render
you know done
but that that's that's what makes it
look like a practical effect and then
also like because he wasn't there
in the same uh pass where the explosions
were happening we added in all the
pieces that actually interact with them
it looks like he's uh projected camera
project we did so we didn't make him a
full digital asset but we had a 3d
representation of him and we reprojected
we needed the 3d for the things to
bounce off of him but also we were able
to change the lighting
because he's walking downstairs where
there's no smoke there's no debris
around him so we were creating shadows
that's that's not good
so you worked on a film called free guy
it was with scanline and i'm imagining
you guys had a lot of destruction
there's just so much stuff happening
yeah it's it's so crazy to watch you
know we actually shot in boston uh
camaro on a street and uh we used that
as our basically our reference and we
you know try to honor that as closely as
possible you know what you what you get
when you're in a city is when the sun is
reflecting it bounces off the windows
and then it puts reflection on the
ground and like there's all these
complexities and that was kind of like
what we were trying to achieve is first
make it look like a city and you know
add all those little things that make it
real and then
turn into a trash compactor
much like the scene in star wars you
know where the walls are caving in on
them and that's i kind of you know
always look at that and that that's been
that was the inspiration at least for me
everything pushes everything like our
visual effects artists they built this
thing called the street squeeze world
machine
uh and basically it's a plug-in you can
get on no after effects
i wish
and basically as the building moves it
pushes the cement the cement crumbles
the cement rolls over it then gets to
the street the asphalt crumbles it
pushes the car then the tree you know so
it's like this happens this happens and
then our team was able to build this
thing that had all the dynamics built in
and then
on top of that we could uh animate any
section of it have a tree fall or you
know animate the car to you know feel
like it has more shocks you know at the
end of the day we had a lot of control
over the sequence and you know the
filmmakers like when we started showing
them stuff they couldn't believe it like
usually when you do a movie you start
cutting it you know all the pieces
shorter and shorter and they were coming
back to us and like can you add some
more frames like we don't have enough
handles
you know and which was a compliment you
know they used every frame because you
know they didn't realize at the end of
the day it was like oh that's really
what it looks like
that's cool so if this is all like in
one file like how do you work on that
how does an artist like work through
that process you know for a 3d artist
you know sometimes it takes 15-20
minutes just to load a scene
that's i think a good example of like
all right we're going to break the file
up a little bit here where we have our
main area where everything's interacting
right and then all the stuff that's not
close to camera where we're not going to
have lighting shifts we can push that
back and separate passes of that you
bring up a really good point because
what saved us and what got us through is
we had this thing called the jump camera
and basically we would take the first
middle last frame and we would render it
every night and then we would basically
look at it and we can tell like what's
in the back like what's important and
instead of building this high res street
you know for 12 blocks which is what
this street is we basically look through
the jump camera and go okay what is the
high res element that we need and we
focused on just on a per shot basis what
what it was that we had to focus on and
build and you know put the effort into
like this movie for me you know this and
like roland emmerich movies like i'm my
four-year-old kid
yeah i was one of those kids i i had a
super 8 camera and i would take
firecrackers i'd build a model and then
i shoot it blowing up you know or put it
on fire
and that's kind of like you know this is
the my version of doing that now you're
getting paid to do that
i want to ask you about water so i feel
like scanline got its start with water
simulations yeah the owner of scanline
stefan troyansky he started as a coder
and seeing all the hollywood visual
effects stuff he's like how do we stand
out and so he basically wrote
the water software flow line and it's
kind of been our base of what we do at
scanline because water is really hard i
worked on titanic and at the time it was
like water oh my god you know now you
can buy off the shelf software that does
water but not only did stefan
write the software but he also wrote the
tools
to break up the simulations on a hundred
cpus
whereas before you would have to run it
on
you know one machine but he figured out
how to
simulate over multiple machines and
that's why it's all about that iteration
like you know that feedback and that's
how we get it closer to reality when i
worked on titanic you know i was
compositing one shot for three months
straight and like i would six days
hitting notes we'd film it out for for
all of those people who were wondering
what film it out means that means
literally printing your render to film
right yeah then get a whole round of
notes and start all over again it would
literally take a week to turn around
the notes from the week before if you
don't check your render and then you're
like oh here film it out i i mean i've
had like things popping off
like and you don't want to be in that
screening room with like jim cameron and
all of a sudden you're like okay dailies
and then oh
who worked on their side
i think there was a collection hard
drive
you know what scanline does is you know
we we've worked with water we break it
down like you know even the glints the
highlights like the white water you know
we are looking at reference constantly
because you can never take anything for
granted one of the reasons i wanted to
ask about water is clearly compared to
like water from like when air force one
crashes into the ocean this is so much
more advanced but it's not photo real
yet right and in your opinion what do
what would it take to get this to be
photo real well i i think making a lake
right
we can make that photo real
but if you you tell the water to bark
like a dog
[Laughter]
you know like this we're making a
tsunami that's a hundred feet tall and
you know there's definitely some
creative license i mean a lot of this
looks really real
yeah but not to him
i love that analogy about making the
lake park like a dog
like we i worked on stealth which you
guys
honored us with saying that it was some
good cg our director rob cohen he wanted
it we showed him like the floating
dirigible and it was leaking fuel and
then it caught on fire and literally
he's like i want it to bark like a dog
and we're all like looking at each other
like
[Laughter]
i want that fire to end so we were like
like so as it's coming it's
you know uh but those are the things you
get you know bark like a dog or
you know it looks cg or painterly like
all these things you have to like okay
what does that mean like i hate being on
the the the other end of that note like
when a director gives you like look cg
or looks painterly how do i tell that to
my artist like they're looking at me
like okay what's the note well it's
simple you turned on the painterly
slider right oh it was the oil paint
filter we put over there
oh my god that shot's incredible there's
something about that one shot in
particular that really stands out to me
everyone like the people in the cars on
the bridge it feels like they're
reacting
most of our job is like how do we make
it look real because this can never
really happen you know strip down what
are the physics like you can look on
youtube and you see bridges where the
wind is and you know it the engineering
is weird and then all of a sudden it
starts moving and so we were using that
and then also the wires that hold it so
we're like well it's one of those breaks
you know and there's a chain reaction
you know it would buckle and
that's the fun part it's like okay
what should it look like like because
there's no button that says simulate and
you know what i mean it's like you
really like you have to go through and
you run it and then you're like the
beginning is cool but i don't like it
the end you know and it's just
iteration after iteration until finally
you're like okay let's render this and
see what it looks like i i worked on uh
gi joe rise of cobra and we had to do
the eiffel tower collapsing we actually
hired an engineering firm and basically
said how would this fall like what would
happen where would it break
where where are the areas that will you
know fail first but that's the fun like
you know figuring all that stuff out i
know this would never happen but if it
did
how would it look
this is one of the most difficult
episodes for me to be a part of because
i can't stop watching
the footage
i just keep getting sucked in there's so
much to watch i love it destruction is
such a fun thing to watch in films and
if you have any scenes from films where
huge things blow up or things rip apart
let us know in the comments and we'll
check them out
this was like again they were showing us
the storyboards the animatic of the
sequence and i'm like you want me to
work on that that's cool
oh i get to blow up a mansion on point
doom in malibu that's awesome they had
storyboarded like this sequence and most
of it is digital you know especially all
the wide shots we couldn't actually
shoot plates
around point doom because
it's a preserve or a national park and
you can only get 500 feet away and so
they came to us early before even
shooting and said you know this has to
be a full digital environment we did get
in a helicopter and we did you know if i
had 500 feet you know with the long
lenses and basically reconstructed point
doom using photogrammetry then building
out the rest of the environment you know
and they built a set that would collapse
so that you know a lot of this was
practical and then we were adding uh
obviously all the glass and but that
that was a real
hole that we just added all the you know
the fine detail around it it was really
complex
so this shot right here i see all this
detail
you know all this environment work the
rocks et cetera and the finished shot i
really don't see much of that work
anymore i just kind of see the glow
now is that something where you guys
built up the detail and as notes happen
it just kind of ended up like this or is
that just something you have to do even
though you know at the end you're going
to be putting
so much haze and glow on it that you
don't see much of the detail one thing i
have learned over the years it's like if
you take a plate and you put the
background out of focus like a lot of
people like oh well it's going to be out
of focus you don't have to put any
detail and that's actually not correct
because if you have something with no
detail and put it out of focus it looks
like crap
but if it's real right it has a lot of
detail then you put it out of focus you
it even though it's out of focus you see
the complexity right if you have rocks
and then all of a sudden it's out of
focus it's all the detail in that real
rock that makes it look like a real rock
out of focus
yeah um but for for example this you
know the waters around uh california
there's not a lot of clarity like you
you know you you can only see so far
before it starts clouding up and getting
hazy if everything was crystal clear
then it would really start looking fake
and so we
made sure that we were creating the
detail and then essentially
hiding it you know i'm working on shots
right now upstairs and sometimes have
like a bad 3d model for the background
so i blur it more and i'm like it's not
making it look better no
it still looks like crap it's just
blurry crap yes exactly
hey guys did you know that seth rogen
has a book well thanks to today's
sponsor audible i'm going to tell you a
little bit about it the book is called
yearbook and it chronicles seth rogen's
life from his childhood through his
career and he notably drops a lot of
really interesting stories like i had no
idea just how intense of a thing that
whole north korea situation was or how
insane nicholas cage kind of is
he has an insane story about kanye west
too
and tom cruise it's a very entertaining
book it actually plays out a lot like a
show because he actually hires a whole
bunch of his friends and actual real
people to voice their characters in his
book but the only way you can hear that
is by going to audible.com quarter crew
or by texting corridor crew to 500 500.
audible is of course the leading
provider of spoken word entertainment
and it's all in one place you can get
the best sellers the new releases
they've got a whole plus catalog as well
kind of like a library card they have a
whole bunch of audiobooks that you can
just get for free included in your
membership and of course you get one
free book it doesn't matter what book it
is every single month they've even got
podcasts in fact seth rogen's podcast
story time is here as well i recommend
that one too and you can of course get
started by going to audible.com quarter
crew or just simply texting quarter crew
to 500500
so thanks for sticking around through my
favorite type of ad segment but for now
let's get back to the couch i'm gonna
transform into future sam
brian thank you so much for joining us
it's been an absolute pleasure do you
have any give any advice for all the uh
visual effects artists or want to be
visual effects artists out there you
know as cool as these shots look there's
a lot of hard work and you know i'm just
one person of them out of a million to
be honest and uh it's a passion
job and you know stick with it and have
fun and take care of yourselves you know
i'm a big fan of bill and ted
so be excellent to each other thank you
brian i really appreciate you joining us
on this summer it's been wonderful
you've had a bunch of amazing insights
i'm just i'm so fortunate to be able to
be joined by guests like you who
honestly you know i've looked up to you
and people like you for for so long
trying to get into doing visual effects
well it's only because you
i've never been on the bad cg side
if i trust me i wouldn't have come if i
was on the backseat
i'd be like no you can work it out